Thank You representative Brady
representative Cummings representative
Hinchey representative Snyder I
appreciate the invitation to be here
today on behalf of the congressional
oversight panel and to be as helpful to
you as I can I should start by saying I
am not scripted so since I don't have a
pre-approved script you should take my
comments as my comments alone and not
necessarily reflecting those of the
panel I will do my best to represent the
reports but otherwise you're hearing
from me I want to say about the
Congressional Oversight Panel we are the
smallest of the oversight units here
particularly compared with the Special
Inspector General what we try to do is a
fact-based analysis of the operations
under the toxic asset relief program and
the impact of that program we're really
trying hard to see what the
effectiveness is and to make
recommendations that might make it more
effective we return to the same themes
that we started with our very first
report about transparency accountability
and clarity throughout the system and
they appear again in the report that we
issued today so I thought I'd start with
just a brief overview of that report and
then very quickly a little dance through
our earlier reports to remind you what
they've been about and to be here then
for whatever questions might be useful
you may remember that back in early
February Treasury and the Federal
Reserve announced s cap yet another
acronym this time to assess the ability
of the 19 largest bank holding companies
to remain well capitalized even under
adverse circumstances the results were
reported just recently and so for our
June oversight report we examine the
stress test we went back and took a hard
look at the stress test we've been
working on it now for over a month since
the program was initially announced and
here's sort of our headline findings I
know that you
you've had a chance to look at the
report but I want to make sure it's out
there as part of our conversation we
looked first at the model for
calculating the report we looked at the
economic assumptions in it we looked at
the question about replicability that is
how robust is this test we looked at the
limitations of the data that are used in
the stress test and we make some
recommendations going forward both as to
transparency of the tests and
appropriate circumstances perhaps for
repeating the stress test so let me
start by giving you some I think some
very good news about the stress test and
that is it's it's always good to believe
things that you're told but it's also
good to verify them independently so we
were very concerned about just the model
of the stress test you know there's a
lot of a lot of dispute in the in the
economic world in the academic world
about how stress tests have been used
and whether they've been very effective
so we asked who independent experts
professor Eric Talley and professor
Johan Walden people who are known
internationally to take a look at the
model that Treasury used and the way
Treasury constructed its model and give
us an idea of what they thought about it
and they came back and said it was a
very conservative model it was a well
conservative meaning of a dependable
model a good model for stress testing
they gave it a lot of support
we got a long and detailed report for
that from them and we've put it into our
report as part of Appendix 1 and very
much integrated into our work but they
identify limits from the stress test as
we then do in our report the first of
them is the question about the worst
case scenario part of the point of a
stress test you know as any family that
sits around and runs a stress test
trying to figure out what would happen
you've got to think what are your worst
economic assumptions that you're going
to be laid off that your credit card
interest rates may go up that you may be
in default on your mortgage
what what is it you need to worry about
here
well the stress test said for 2009 one
of the key economic assumptions under
the worst case scenario would be an
eight point nine percent unemployment
rate we're now at nine point four
percent now the projection made back in
February it seemed like a reasonable
projection at the time unemployment
obviously rose more quickly than we had
anticipated the average for the year to
this point counting the earlier months
when it was lower is eight point five
percent which means we have not actually
broken through the worst case scenario
but let's face it the numbers are bad
and they have headed in the wrong
direction
so this is a real concern that the worst
case scenario right here in 2009 is in
fact not the worst case we're going to
see worse numbers than that the second
concern is the limited time horizon the
modeling is always tricky the further
out you try to model it predicting the
weather the further out you try to go
the more possibility there's error the
more possibility that you may not be
accurate on the other hand if you
particularly if you have reason to know
there are things you should be concerned
about in the future it it you could
ignore that future time only at your
peril the point of a stress test is to
tell us about the financial health of
these institutions and whether or not
they're going to be able to survive
going forward our concerns do not stop
with December of 2010 but the stress
test does the period of time that is
particularly worrisome because of the
state of the commercial real estate
mortgages they are on a longer period
for when they will come up to be
refinanced so that numbers we were we
were supplied numbers by representative
from Deutsche Bank they're in our report
on an annual basis the numbers for 2011
2012 2013 are deeply worrisome and the
question about the adequacy of capital
reserve requirements looking at
potential losses
on into the future really does say the
stress tests would be stronger and more
meaningful if they reached across a
longer period of time and dealt with
this issue the third problem that we are
concerned about is the inability to
replicate the tests I'm afraid I'm going
to expose once again my academic
background I do a lot of empirical work
and one of the most important things
that you want to do in any model is is
established that it is robust and and
what we mean by robust is just if
something changed slightly if the you
altered the time period a little bit
then the GDP contraction or growths
shifted just slightly do you get
relatively similar results different
results but but within the same ballpark
if you do then you have a lot of
confidence that the test ism is
measuring something real that is that
it's robust the problem is you can't
rerun those tests unless you have enough
details about them and so we've pressed
very hard on the Fed who is really the
custodian of this test for more
information not about specific banks but
about the operation how how exactly I
mean down at a gritty level how these
mathematical formulas work how the
pieces link into each other we have not
been able to get that information and
without that information others
Outsiders are not able to push on the
stress tests in the same way and then
finally we would be remiss if we fail to
note this is self-reported information
it is not independently verified
information and it is overseen by the
same regulators that we have had in
place throughout the process and this
this raises questions about confidence
overall so that brings us to our
recommendations here we recommend that
the stress test should be repeated under
more difficult economic circumstances
and over
longer time period for obvious reasons
it's a way to test it to see how it
works we recommend that the test should
continue as long as the banks continue
to hold large amounts of toxic assets
this is a risky situation and an
appropriate time to repeat these tests
we recommend that banks be required to
run internal to stress tests between
official reporting periods and share
those results with their regulators in
other words I want to make it clear here
while we have concerns about the stress
test we think there are ways to
strengthen them and we embrace the
stress test we think that the stress
test was a good move by Treasury and the
Fed and that it has brought us important
information indeed as I push for more
transparency because that's the second
big category of recommendation more
transparency more accountability in the
system Treasury should release more
details of their methodology and the
results and publicly track the status of
the macroeconomic assumptions this is
just an important part of of doing this
we want the analysts to be able to run
these tests independently I want to put
this on a spectrum though we had trouble
when we first started the congressional
oversight panel back in November and in
December that we had a Treasury
Department that was not forthcoming with
information that has changed the
Treasury Department has been forthcoming
they have given us far more information
and I don't just mean to the
Congressional Oversight Panel they have
made available information under the
stress test an unprecedented amount of
data this is very unusual for the
Federal Reserve to make the results of
tests like this available other than
simply to make announcements at the end
about you know as the FDIC does when an
institution has been placed on the
watchlist or closed
we simply are asking for more we think
that the tests were a good idea but they
would we would get more effectiveness
from them if we had
Changez if we if we made them stronger
one last recommendation I want to
mention here we also want to point out
that as much as we think capital
adequacy reserves are important the
capital tests are important it is
important that bank should not be forced
into counterproductive fire sales that
they sell under enormous pressure in
order to try to raise enough cash so so
we very much see the importance of
flexibility in dealing with the
institutions that are not able to meet
the capital reserve requirements are
that are only closed and we want to we
want to repose some confidence with our
regulators in this area so those are the
recommendations coming out of the June
report which is just issued this morning
hot off the presses I'm just going to
give you a quick summary of our earlier
reports just to remind you of the kinds
of things we've talked about and I'm
glad to talk about any of these reports
our December and January reports pose 10
primary questions to the Treasury
Department about their goals and their
methods to stabilize the markets and to
reduce foreclosures I think it's fair to
say that secretary Paulson's answers
were often non-responsive that they were
incomplete and in some cases elusive
additional information on bank
accountability transparency asset
valuation foreclosures and strategy must
be provided we have been pushing on that
from the beginning the February report
evaluated whether or not the securities
that Treasury had received in exchange
for the infusion of cash under the
initial healthy banks program the
capital infusion program and then
ultimately the support for AIG
whether or not of what the taxpayer
received in response was fairly valued
secretary Paulson in his response to our
inquiry about this in December responded
by saying that
all of those transactions had taken
place in his words a poor near par which
means for every hundred dollars put in
that the American taxpayer received a
hundred dollars worth of stock and
warrants we did an independent valuation
and discovered that for every hundred
dollars put in on average we received
$66 in stock and warrants so an
important report on valuation I should
say very much arguing in this report we
would have known that we were creating
these subsidies from the very way the
program was structured from the
beginning there have not been additional
infusions under that program since
February the third the March report
examined the foreclosure crisis with
particular focus on the impediments to
the mortgage mitigation why it is that
we're not able to stop these
foreclosures what it is we could do to
help with these foreclosures this report
came out only a few days after the
administration's foreclosure mitigation
program was announced we had established
some criteria for evaluating that and we
talked in that report about some ways in
which we think the administration
program was good but some ways in which
it very much needed to be strengthened
in our April report we highlighted the
benefits and the problems of basic
approaches to dealing with financial
institutions in trouble we had experts
in to talk with us about how Japan dealt
with its banks when they were in
financial crisis expert from Sweden we
had someone who had been part of the RTC
here in the United States when the
savings and loans collapsed and someone
who was a specialist on the Great
Depression that was in our in our
hearing in addition to that we did lots
of other studies about other times other
circumstances we came away from that
saying that successful efforts to deal
with failing financial institution have
as institutions had all
always been marked by transparency
assertiveness in dealing with the
financial institutions demanding greater
accountability from the financial
institutions and clarity in the programs
what it is that the government was about
and what it was trying to do our may
report the last report before this one
considered the state of small business
and consumer lending and whether the
telegram was well designed to attract
new capital we concluded that there are
serious problems in the small business
lending area we thought it was a much
more mixed picture in terms of consumer
lending with small business lending our
conclusion was that the health program
was not likely to make a big difference
in the availability of credit for small
and mid-sized businesses once again as I
think has been the case with each of our
reports we concluded that in a crisis
transparency accountability and a
clearly delineated plan is what will be
essential for getting us out of the
economic crisis that's a description of
our current report and just a thumbnail
of our earlier reports and I'm glad to
help if I can with any questions thank
you very much for you for your testimony
professor Warren one of your principal
recommendations is to repeat the stress
tests so long as banks continue to hold
large amounts of toxic assets yet the
stress tests take bank accounting value
as their starting point and explicitly
avoid marking certain toxic assets to
market so my question to you is do you
think that an effort should be made to
recognize the losses on these toxic
assets
well congresswoman you know this is this
is the ultimate and everything is
related to everything and if we don't
have confidence in the books and what it
is that the financial institutions hold
publicly to be there worth what their
assets are worth and what their
liabilities are worth it undermines not
only confidence in the whole system it
really does mean that we we are
continuing to run risks mark-to-market
is not the only way to develop some
confidence in the value of the assets
held by the financial institutions but
there is no doubt that any stress test
and frankly any any analysis of the
current health of these financial
institutions and how they trade on Wall
Street depends on some confidence that
these assets are correctly valued so so
let me let me simply emphasize the
importance of transparency I will leave
it to the accountants to continue to
argue over the right way to get that but
but to say without it we cannot rebuild
our financial system we cannot build it
on clouds we have to build it on reality
and reality is what those assets are
really worth so so do you think that
bank lending will be affected if they
continue to carry the unrecognized
losses on their books well to the extent
that every time the banks raise capital
they're concerned about these losses and
they hold that capital against the the
future losses they hold it in reserve
those are dollars that are not available
for lending
it's just that straightforward if the
banks are not in a stronger financial
position they will not lend risk at some
banks were hidden in off-balance sheet
vehicles only to be brought back on to
bank balance sheets as these vehicles
experienced losses do you think the
stress tests have been successful in
identifying where off-balance sheet
problems may arise over the next two
years well I want to say something
complementary here the good news is this
stress test was designed to bring the
off-balance-sheet
vehicles back and include them I think
that the stress test without that would
have been a non-starter if we're going
to continue to hide risks off the
balance sheet so that's the good news
they were brought back in I hope that
everything has been included but I have
to say these are self-reported numbers I
I have no personal access and my panel
has no access to to any additional
information or any data that's that's
just outside what what we're able to see
and today it's been announced that major
institutions will be repaying their tarp
money that they are capitalized and
ready to repay the government how will
this repaid tarp money be used will it
be recycled in new lending or will it go
back to the Treasury what will be the
use of this return tarp money I believe
based on what secretary Geithner has
said that the money will be held at
least to be available to be Reis pent I
think that this statute is at best
ambiguous on whether this money can be
recycled or whether this money must be
returned to the Treasury and given the
ambiguity the Treasury Department
certainly at least has grounds for
interpreting it the way they want to
interpret it so I think that's what
they're going to do with the money
unless Congress tells them differently
thank you my time is expired and mr.
Brady's recognized five minutes right
Thank You professor Warren a madam
chairman professor Warren recently Neil
Barofsky special inspector general for
the bailout dollars issued a disturbing
report that identifies many key
weaknesses in the design and
implementation of government bailouts he
called several recommendations he he
called on Treasury Department to adopt
recommendations that all the tarp
recipients simply account for the use of
their tarp funds
that they set up internal controls to
comply with such accounting and report
periodically to Treasury on the results
with appropriate sworn certifications
you support those recommendations yes
congressman I do although I really want
to point out that much of this falls on
the the smaller financial institutions
and and the very responsible financial
institutions whose horses never left the
barn and that the problem we have is
that we're doing this six months after
the fact if if we had set this program
up last October to say you only get the
money when you describe in advance what
you plan to do with it and give us
metrics for how we will measure that we
would be in a very different position
today today we're in the position of
asking after the fact how did you spend
the money that you received and quite
frankly given the fungibility of money
after the fact that's a that's a pretty
tough one to have to have much
accountability appreciate that but it
seems to me the American public wasn't
like we lent these banks five dollars
and see keep track of it we lent them
billions of dollars with the
understanding they would be used in in
key ways and it seems to me banks and
financial institutions that can track
your credit card to the dime anywhere in
the world can track these dollars at any
point they wish it seems to me odd to
have the Congressional Oversight Panel
which is supposed to be our eyes and
ears not joining in every call to make
sure these dollars are used
transparently and with clarity I also
question just how effective the panel
has been over the past six months of
your existence
how many Tommy hearings have you held
with the Treasury Department as a
witness I understand it's it's only one
we've had we've been able to get
secretary Geithner
and to testify once we ask secretary
Paulson repeatedly we have asked
secretary Geithner repeatedly you know I
I remind you that Congress did not give
us subpoena power we only have the
capacity to invite so you asked
secretary Paulson in the first month
existence yeah well I believe we asked
him repeatedly
we asked him in our first month in our
second month in our third month so
you've had one hearing with someone from
Treasury who's who's running an
implementing Treasury we've and then if
I my understandings one and then how
many hearings have we had with the
recipients of the tarp funds well we've
had various field hearings where we've
just a normal congressional hearing with
them as witnesses to determine how they
use the tarp funds what was the
effectiveness of it you know all the
things we task right
I believe that would be our our
Milwaukee hearing I believe that would
be our Prince George's County hearing
and excuse me you have the major banks
actually I'll say once again we have
invited the major financial institutions
to come without subpoena power we have
no way to insist on them yes we have had
financial institutions and yes we have
had tarp recipients but we have not been
able to get every one that we invited we
we do not have subpoena power Colin
Smith all due respect I don't know how
this panel could be fulfilling its
responsibility having one hearing with
Treasury and and the answer is none with
the banks and financial institutions as
witnesses it just seems to me you know
we tasked you with a great deal of
responsibility and so far it's been it's
not a reflection on you that's been very
disappointing there's been very little
value that the panel has brought to this
issue or even insight on how these
bailout dollars have been used the
information is for the most part been
redundant except for the Fed with the
exception of your February report which
I applaud
I think the panel's failed to bring
transparency and clarity to tarp and I
think it's it's a the result is and it's
exemplified by there is no public
confidence and how the payoff dollars
being used there's no feeling they're
being done transparently or
accountability and there's no
congressional support which is why again
I think they're going through
extraordinary lengths to not ask for any
more dollars because there is no public
support or congressional support for
this I I frankly believe at this point
given the reports that we've seen again
with with little value I think the panel
needs to be abolished and it needs to be
reconstituted in a form that actually
create will incite real analysis of a
program that has only grown larger now
that the repayment of the financial
dollars begins to be a revolving slush
fund for use of the original tarp
dollars so that's my feeling on this
issue
I want to thank the gentleman for his
statements and concern about
transparency and to welcome him to
co-sponsor with me bill 1242 the tarp
accountability and Disclosure Act and
this bill would require the Secretary of
the Treasury to create a centralized
database for the existing financial
report of tarp recipients enhancing our
ability to better understand how these
dollars are being spent
as the professor pointed out she has no
subpoena power so if she requests this
information it is not necessarily coming
forward but this is an opportunity for
us to require by law that this
information be made available for for
for members of Congress on both sides of
the aisle for others to study and
understand so I I think this would be a
step in the right direction and I would
also like to invite professor Warren to
look at this legislation and get back to
us with your recommendations on how we
might move forward with it
I now recognize me I would support that
I think that's great
I do did just hear the professor say
it's too late to hold those institutions
accountable for the dollars and that it
is a burden on the smaller institution
but I think that's a great approach I
think it's important to understand what
happened so that we have better policy
going forward and possibly this research
and accountability Disclosure Act could
be expanded to other information in the
financial system so that we could
possibly better prevent such actions in
the future I welcome your support thank
you so very much mr. Cummings I joined
you to manager I agree the last thing I
want to do is a abolish oversight that's
the thing we need the most and the
American people watching this I hope
that they understand that this Congress
is concerned about oversight and I can
understand mr. Brady's one effective and
efficient oversight but the fact is is
that we've got a we've got to make sure
we do what needs to be done and on that
note I miss Professor Warren I want to
thank you for you for what you've done I
think you've done an outstanding job I
understand that there's certain
limitations but I want to go to
something else you talked a little bit
about foreclosures that was I think
March report this week and I something
interesting happened in the 7th
congressional district of Maryland 40
miles away from here
we held a foreclosure prevention meeting
well we a thousand people who were
losing their homes came in to Morgan
State University I pursue answered it
and an interesting thing happened we
were able to I would eventually guess
out of that thousand people we were able
to help at least say four or five
hundred at least modify their mortgages
they had an opportunity to literally sit
down professor with 19 banks or mortgage
companies service companies and in doing
a exit during my exit interviews we
discovered that the banks were reducing
mortgage payments by anywhere between
$300 per month and 1,100 a month and I'm
trying to figure out you know and the
scene and talking to the banking people
I was a little bit surprised that they
were so anxious to make these
modifications that we frankly I was
shocked I thought we help some people
but not that
and I'm just wondering you know in light
of that kind of thing we're gonna get
ready to do it again in another three
months because we gotta help people stay
in their homes but you know is there a
new approach when these kinds of things
I mean from user have you seen anything
from say these mortgage lending folks
where by I mean that and and as to how
they deal with that these kinds of when
they for modify a loan whether they're
dealing with that in a different way on
their books are you following me I I
think so congressman and the answer is
you know this is one where we kept
thinking the mortgage modifications
would occur because they made sense
economically yeah it hurts to take the
hit you know that you're you're not
going to get a payment of one hundred
and twenty thousand dollars at nineteen
percent interest over time some of these
crazy mortgages that it was better to
cut down take less but keep the
homeowner in place good from the
homeowners point of view but also good
from the point of view of the mortgage
company get this back to a performing
loan albeit at a a lower level but a
steady payment that's going to occur we
thought they would occur and frankly
they just didn't in the numbers that we
expected and that's why the
administration tried different plans you
may remember back earlier under the
previous administration you know there
were these voluntary plans the key seems
to be the sort of thing that you were
doing and that is finding a way to get
the homeowners and the mortgage lenders
somebody who really has the authority to
make changes and get them in one place
at one time in the hearings we have held
the field hearings we've held about this
the research that we've done over and
over we hear about those who are trying
to modify who can't get anybody on the
phone right right okay get anybody to
respond who have to start every time
they call again they have to start anew
with someone to get told one thing by
one person something else by someone
someone different this notion of
bringing people together whether it's
physically bringing them together
whether it's finding someone who can get
the
together on the telephone seems to be
the most promising Avenue that we have
so I applaud you on behalf of the four
to five hundred families will be better
off the mortgage lenders who will be
better off under these circumstances and
hope that we can we're looking for ways
to try to scale that up and make sure
that it happens across the country let
me ask you this in light of the
government's injection the big uns of
dollars in working capital and other
assistance into the auto industry should
they have been a stress test run on
Chrysler and GM it's a it's an
interesting question of obviously as
part of this reorganization of these two
entities part of what confirmation of a
chapter 11 plan will entail is something
called feasibility that is this plan is
going to work and this company is
expected to survive going forward in the
case of large Chapter 11 this is not
because the government's involved this
is just in general there are a lot of
ways that that occurs a lot of ways that
those tests are are conducted and in
effect the the industries the companies
and their creditors have been running
variations on stress test for a long
time now with financially troubled
institutions I'd be surprised if there's
not some variation on it in the case of
the auto companies thank you very much
Thank You congressman thank you very
much I think yeah just based on the
number of dollars that have gone to the
automobile companies and GMAC
I think I think
participating in the stress test is it's
something we should do let me ask you
this congressman Brady may have actually
asked this already so I apologize if me
being late requires you to answer it
twice but it's so important that people
need to hear it
have-have has your panel disclosed to
the American people whether or
not tarp is working well we can't
disclose what what is it known we've
disclosed as much as we can we've
addressed this in our various reports
the secretary of the Treasury says there
are some positive indicators and there
are some negative indicators still in
the economy and that's the best we can
do we can see changes we try to document
those and we try to point out where
where there continue to be weaknesses
you know this this isn't resolved yet
congressman I'm sorry it's just not
we're we're still in amid crisis and
there are both up arrows and down arrows
let me yeah look let me ask you this we
had the Special Inspector General here
before this committee a few weeks ago
and a special inspector general Borowski
testified that there were almost 20
criminal investigations underway in
connection with the tarp facility for
the financial sector and his report said
these investigations in Paul would
involve possible public corruption
corporates truck stock and tax fraud
insider trading and mortgage fraud and
in an NPR interview he stated that one
of the probes involves bank officials
who are allegedly cooking the books in
order to qualify for tarp money so are
you aware is your committee aware of
this issue and have you got any
additional information about these yeah
we work very closely with the special
inspector general and I should make
clear if there was any misunderstanding
when I spoke with congressman Brady
we support the special inspector
general's efforts we are very pleased
this is Special Inspector General has
asked for the tarp recipients to account
for the money they have received I've
testified about this before and
expressed our support my only point is
it's it's hard to do that after the fact
and we just we don't want to it is
different from what it would have been
if we had asked at the beginning in
terms of me
able to account for where the money is
gone but yes we work with the Special
Inspector General we meet with him on a
weekly or more often basis I was on the
phone with him yesterday morning so we
are aware of their activities we we
support their activities and we try to
coordinate with their activities and be
helpful in all ways that we can is there
any aspect of that that has been a
surprise to you well it's it's always a
surprise when in the in the sense of I
perhaps the better word would be
disappointment when we discover that
there are people who have abused public
trust but that's why we're here to do
oversight that's why we have a special
inspector general that's why we have a
congressional oversight panel we're here
to have in effect two functions to call
it out when we see it and as a result to
try to act as a deterrent so there will
be less of it you think you're better
able to anticipate some of the problems
that might occur the future from the
from what you've learned from past
experiences absolutely and are those
procedures are you employing those
procedures today we we do and we change
not just with every monthly report we
evolve we are we are a small panel we
are a small group and we adjust you know
treasure itself has changed over the
past seven months the nature of the
economic crisis has changed over the
last seven months and we have changed
both as we have learned and asked new
problems have presented themselves we've
tried to be as responsive as we can and
as nimble as we can to try to deal with
the problems as they arrived just in the
brief time I have remaining
the the issue of stock warrants has come
up from time to time and the concern is
that some banks were we're forced to
accept tarp funds and provided stock
warrants to the government and for these
banks to depart now buyback these
warrants they'd have to pay a price that
actually would reflect a very high
interest rate on funds that were held
for only a few month
regarding that the banks that some of
the banks alleged they did not need the
funds in the first place what do we do
about the about this fact and the Allah
quiddity of the warrant says these banks
try to restore themselves to the to
their pre tarp status good so let me
just say as briefly as I can three
things about this the first one is the
valuation of the warrants takes place in
the shadow of our February valuation of
the stock and warrant transactions for
the initial infusion about three hundred
and fifty billion dollars into the banks
I think that's important because it is a
very public reminder to Treasury and to
the financial institutions that there
are ways to value this there are
evaluation experts and while there may
be some differences we can review these
transactions and we have made it clear
that we will review these transactions
so I think that's the first thing to
remember about the warrants the second
thing I want to say is that this is the
subject of our July report we are
already at work on valuation of the
warrants and some of the issues involved
in that and so we will have a report on
that approximately 30 days from today
the third is to say you raise however in
this the point that there is a larger
issue than simply the dollars in the
valuation of a warrant and that is some
profound policy questions about the
representations that were made at the
beginning for the financial institutions
as they entered this program and what
what is fair under the circumstances as
well as what is right for the economy I
hope that that is something we'll also
be able to address in our report but I
certainly see the issue congressman and
I think that's the starting place for
having a thoughtful conversation on it
if I may what are some of the barriers
to being able to do that I'm sorry the
gentleman's time is expired but you may
answer that very quickly I'm sorry I
don't understand the question
the barriers that when you're
last point we used that you you do want
to be able to evaluate those fairly what
are some of the barriers that that might
occur that would prevent that or make
that more difficult there there are five
people on this panel and what issues
they want to take on will depend you've
got to have at least three people who
want to talk about that set of issues so
I hope that this is an issue that we
will be able to address but I simply
can't commit my my fellow panelists on
that the gentleman's time I think that's
important I hope you will follow up
thank you thank you mr. Hinchey is
recognized for five minutes
thank you very much madam chairman and
professor thank you once again for
everything that you're doing I mean
you're inspirational and frankly I wish
that we had given you more power
including subpoena power because I think
that you would have used that very
effectively in the context of these
circumstances that you and we are
dealing with I think it's pretty clear
that the economic circumstances that
this country is facing these dire
circumstances near depression
circumstances we're caused by the
manipulation of investment practices
some years ago the falsification of
information in the context of those
investment practices now we have some
continuing falsification of information
one which you cited specifically not
long ago in the context of your remarks
with regard to getting back 66 percent
rather than a hundred percent of the
money that is being put in and also the
full accountability of the seven hundred
billion dollars which was not issued by
the Congress as a grant to anybody to
just use in whatever way they want and
keep but as a kind of a loan no interest
loan but alone which was to be used to
bail out the banking circumstances but
as the bailout occurred the repay back
of that money to the people of this
country so what do you think we should
be doing in order to achieve those
objectives do you think that we need
some specific laws and rules and
regulations put in do you think that it
would be wise to give you some
additional power to engage in the
efforts that that you're using and also
there's one other thing that I want to
ask you in the context of this and that
is
the repeal of the glass-steagall Act was
one of the main reasons why we had this
manipulation of investments and the lack
of accountability now I know that that
glass-steagall Act had been manipulated
prior to its elimination back in 1999
but the elimination of that
glass-steagall Act was intentional it
was purposeful and it was designed to
allow the manipulation of these
investment practices to go forward and
more aggressive and and completely
unaccountable ways so I would appreciate
it if I know you've probably thought
about this should we be putting back
into effect some modern version of the
glass-steagall Act which would cause
that separation of investment and
openness of investment and honesty and
investment and accountability so
congressman let me see if I can do these
all three of these questions very
thoughtful the first one it's obvious if
you want us to do more work we are your
your congressional oversight panel we
are we are here at your pleasure and if
you want us to do more work through
hearings and you want us to be able to
have more Treasury officials appear in
front of us Federal Reserve officials
appear in front of us bankers appear in
front of us we can't do that without
subpoena power this is how you've
designed your panel on the other hand I
should say there's still plenty we can
do even without our subpoena power we
were able to write a report that exposed
misrepresentation about the value of
transactions that were occurring under
tarp and I think that's been very
valuable we've also been able to
evaluate and deal with other parts of
the program and there have been real
changes at Treasury change Treasury is
not operating in the same way it was
operating before so so I think there's a
real effect out there let's let's turn
to your question about glass-steagall I
want to make a point about
glass-steagall in my view glass-steagall
was about systemic risk regulation they
just didn't use the fancy words back
then but the real point was to say they
understood after the depression or in
the depression that we had gone through
these boom and bust cycles every 10 to
15
fifteen years and that the banks were
part of it the banks were big risk
takers they got out there and they
rolled the dice and as long as they made
money their investors got rich and when
they went down they took everyone down
with them they took down all their
depositors and they also took down a lot
of local communities when they did it
the basic understanding behind
glass-steagall was look we can't keep
doing that that's that's not going to
work for us you really do not just hurt
yourself you're not like the the one
little business the hardware story that
goes out of business or that even the
manufacturer that goes out of business
you're taking down a lot with you when
you do this as a financial institution
so the premise behind glass-steagall was
we will create this wall and frankly we
will have boring banks we will have
banks that are run very much like public
utilities they will make only modest
profits but they will be absolutely
rock-solid secure and the risk-taking
will be taken somewhere else where we
don't have to worry about it so if the
the fancy investment houses want to go
out and take those risks that's fine but
they won't take anyone down but
themselves
of course what happened is not only did
we find our not we did the the financial
institutions find ways to get around
glass-steagall and we weaken
glass-steagall the markets matured they
changed so that dividing along a bank
non-bank line as we'd had in
glass-steagall we believe now is not the
most effective way to do it every time
we talk now about systemic risk
regulation we are addressing precisely
the same question that was addressed
during the Depression how do we find a
way to have a certain kind of financial
institution that can hold deposits that
can be safe that can be secure that we
can put our paychecks in that we can
write checks on and know that money can
be transmitted across the country around
the world and how do we separate that
from something that is risky and frankly
either can be allowed to fail without
any government intervention
and without having taxpayer involvement
how can we accomplish that and there's a
lot of conversation around that right
now we have some recommendations in our
own regulatory reform report which I
erroneously hadn't omitted in going
through our monthly reports we also did
a regulatory reform report at your
request so I think that's the issue
congressman it's it's systemic risk
regulation for which glass-steagall had
kept us safe for more than 50 years in a
changed world we're gonna have to have a
new version of it thank you thank you
very very much congressman Schneider
thank you madam chair
first of all I need to make a comment as
you may know our my wife and I we have a
six-month-old today triplet boys plus a
three year old and three months ago my
wife went on leave from her job as a
Methodist minister and which meant we
went from being a two-income family to a
one income family and I'll tell you what
your book made a whole lot more sense to
me the last couple months I appreciate
all the work you've done on the
financial pressures on American families
I want to ask on page 36 of the report
you say quote the most direct way for a
bhc to increase its capital base is to
earn net income from us normal banking
business and add that income to its
capital accounts and then the report
goes on to say they're not going to be
able to earn their way out of it as you
look ahead right my question is can the
opposite occur but by that I mean I'm
not sure what normal banking business is
frankly anymore it seems to me that
sometimes normal banking business is
almost predatory as you see computer
programs that are designed to to
prioritize the processing of debits and
cheques in such a way that it will drive
people in the more overdrafts which is
essentially just loaning money at
exorbitant rates you know what I'm
talking about yes
the chairwoman here has done wonderful
work on dealing with credit cards and
and we
hope I mean I think there's clearly been
predatory behavior there I think
Congress is very interested in looking
at what we would consider normal banking
business now compared to what perhaps it
was in the past and what it ought to be
can we go the other way in which we put
what would would lower the income of
banks in such a way as we get rid of
some of these predatory practices to
where that could put some in jeopardy
too as they've been putting too much of
their business income from things that
they ought already not be doing you know
we talk a lot about the transformation
of the banking world and the investment
world from the wall street perspective
but the real transformation has occurred
at the household level consumer lending
just does not look like it did 30 years
ago
the whole business model has changed you
know the the notion that we carry in our
heads that that some lender looked at
you and evaluated whether or not you'd
be able to repay this added a little bit
for on an interest rate for risk and is
making money by by screening customers
it simply isn't true anymore we've
shifted over to a model where those who
sell these financial instruments let's
just take credit cards for example we'll
identify two or three main things that
you can see the nominal interest rate
which is often not the true cost the
free gift and the warm and fuzzy
relationship with the financial
institution and then the business model
is to pump up revenues and profits with
all the things hidden in the fine print
according to The Wall Street Journal the
typical credit card contract just a
focus there has gone from a page and a
half long in 1982 more than 30 pages
today and that extra 30 pages it's not
put there to help families so I think
it's important in this crisis because
you really get down to the heart of what
it means to have a working financial
system the way I see this this problem
started one household at a time one
lousy mortgage
one overwrought credit card of one bad
loan at a time down at the household
level so much was promised in the way of
profits that those ones were aggregated
they were then put into trust they were
then sold on up the line so that the
riskiness at the household level became
magnified throughout the American
economy and ultimately throughout the
world economy if we go back to a world
where the basic consumer financial
products are just steady and they're
just plain vanilla they're ones that
have a level playing field nobody should
be protected from make a mistake so you
go to the mall and spend $2,000 that you
really can't afford you should have to
pay for that you buy a house with five
bedrooms and a spa bath that you really
can't afford you really should have to
pay for that or lose that house but
ordinary people who've done ordinary
transactions deserve just some ordinary
instruments to be able to do that if
that's the case that will not only help
us at the family level it will
completely reform what our financial
institutions look like and ultimately
give us a far more secure financial
system so in the short run they Bank
then who has been making their income
off of taking advantage of families they
may hurt in the in the short run but in
the long run we as a country our economy
and our whole credit markets will come
out better
absolutely congressman Schneider I can't
say it better than that because that is
the answer thank you thank you thank you
madam chairman thank you for holding
this hearing today thank you for your
leadership and thank you is mourn for
what you're doing I've always believed
that we need to restore stability in our
financial markets and you've been a
leader with that and to do that we have
to get the best possible results for the
American taxpayers at the lowest cost
and to me this means transparency and
accountability and that is your focus
and I believe when you look at the past
previous to this administration there
was not that kind of accountability and
transparency we did not have that and
while there's there's
criticisms we can lob now and we're in a
transition period when you look at what
got us into this mess in the first place
loopholes that were allowed to be opened
and there's blame on both sides for that
the the leverage that was allowed to the
SEC allowed back in they was Oh for and
just a bunch of things that went wrong
from Bernie Madoff on that shouldn't
have happened and so that's why I
appreciate what you're trying to do here
and in a way you're starting from
scratch and we're trying to get here
instead of a short term view of our
economy and our business markets we're
trying to get a long term view on trying
to encourage response will be hey view
so I wanted to start first with these
stress tests I can say that the
announcement of them caused a lot of
stress in our state we have a lot of
banks and in the end I think they fared
well and worked hard and we also have
some small community banks that are
doing well do you foresee these a need
to continue to do these stress tests at
the time when they were first announced
I was very concerned that they the
stress tests themselves had an effect on
the stocks of banks that actually hadn't
gotten into messes because people were
fearful that all the banks were going to
be nationalized and there was all that
kind of talking I think it's even doubt
now after with the results of these
trust stress tests being resolved with
the fact that some of the capital has
been raised but could you talk about
that in terms of going forward and
number one do you see this as a good
sign that the I think it was the
estimates are how much money's been
billions of dollars that have been
raised since the announcement of the
stress test to how do you see them
working going forward yes we embrace the
stress test senator I know they they
made everyone nervous at the beginning
but the consequence ultimately was to
put more information into the
marketplace information that had more
reliability than the rumors that were
circulating as you said when everyone is
worried that oh my gosh you know all the
banks may fail they may all be
nationalized we may have a terrible
crisis here that has a terrible effect
not just on a market but but across the
country what what financial institutions
are going to lend to small businesses
under those circumstances what what
medium-sized businesses are
to expand their inventories if they
think that's where the economy's hurt a
headed poor information puts us in a
position of trading in in scale rumors
so I'm a strong believer that the more
information we can get out there and the
more reliable that information is you
know there'll be some bumps at the
beginning but not only will there be
readjustment we begin to rebuild on a
solid foundation
so my view and I believe our panel's
view on stress tests unanimously here is
yes we like them we think they could be
stronger and we think they should be
used in more ways and more often okay
one of the other things that you've
talked about before is this idea of
systemic risks how a few actors can do
some bad things and then suddenly the
whole system starts going under so we
are looking right now at reforms for
regulating the the market and we want to
do it in a prudent way and we want to do
it quickly what do you think we should
be doing well I'm gonna I'm gonna start
with how to frame the issue because
that's the one that concerns me the most
the the really tricky part in this one
is to identify what it is that puts us
at risk is it sighs is it concentration
is it the kind of industry you work in
you know we've had big companies fail
and long failed it was it was huge
Worldcon failed it was huge and those
businesses were liquidated and they were
liquidated a very short period of time
very serious consequences for example in
the case of Enron employees who were
laid off and I'm not saying it's not
done without pain but I don't know if
you know this and Ron was making the
argument shortly before it was forced
into bankruptcy that it would cost the
systemic failure that it was out there
in the power industry that it was such
an important player in that industry and
of course that wasn't true at all we
said this is the problem this is where
you are financially or
to liquidate so what I want to emphasize
here is the importance as we look at it
about identifying what the risk is
before we just head off and say okay so
here's going to be a make sure we know
what the problem is before we we go to
the solution and if I could I just work
in I know I'm over your time but if I
could work in one other little point and
that is to go back to where you started
just now and that is at the household
level at the family level we're not only
on Chris increased risk for large
institutions and for our biggest banks
who did it for American households
American households now stand at a
hundred and thirty percent of their
annual income in total debt that's a
that's a staggering number we have we
have been hitting numbers that are
unprecedented we've never even close to
these numbers at any point in our
history when we reform financial
products and put some basic safety in so
that families are themselves more
economically stable and we're not
introducing into the stream of financial
commerce these high risk high profit
instruments we turn the risk down in the
system overall and frankly we can deal
with systemic risk with a lighter touch
those who are worried about the heavy
hand of government on systemic risk at
the back end would be well to observe
that modest changes at the front end
could mean that we require less
intervention and less supervision
overall if we make this system solid
from the beginning it'll be solid
throughout thank you very much I'm
looking forward to learning more about I
know the proposal for a financial
commission to help consumers with these
products and I think it's a very
interesting idea thank you
Thank You senator and for your
extraordinary leadership you are truly a
star
we have many competing hearings taking
place on a financial regulation health
care reform and energy
and we are going to be presenting our
future questions to you in writing we
thank you for your time your dedication
your commitment to public service and
your really incredible influence that
you've had on financial reform thank you
very much thank you I'm chairman yes I
ask unanimous consent that my opening
statement be inserted into the record
absolutely and and I would like to say
that everyone has an opportunity to sit
and submit their questions and and and a
meeting is adjourned